spacex dragon and we're go for launch
let's light this candle it was an uneasy
wait but as the countdown came the
clouds cleared three two one zero
ignition liftoff of the Falcon nine and
two American astronauts made history
this is the first time a private company
not a government has been in charge of
sending astronauts into orbit
dr. net cab is clear go for luncheon
with NASA's help SpaceX are launching a
new era of corporate LED human space
missions today is a milestone for its
billionaire founder Elon Musk and for
the two test pilots Doug Hurley and Bob
Behnken after aborting their first
attempt last week they were back today
to try again
this time the weather didn't halt
liftoff and be draggin loud and clear
and the veteran astronauts and Friends
became pioneers of a new world order for
spaceflight we view it as an opportunity
but also a responsibility for the
American people for the SpaceX team for
all of NASA that's put this opportunity
together and and entrusted us with it
it's incredibly humbling to be here to
start out the next launch from the
United States we're looking forward to
getting up close and personal with the
Falcon 9 and crew dragon here liftoff of
space shuttle compliance the last time
the US and humans into orbit was in 2011
since then they've had to piggyback on
Russian projects Donald Trump was so
keen to witness the change he came back
again to watch today even as his country
burned in anger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
half century ago the Apollo moon
missions use this same Launchpad the
spectators are gone but another dream is
realized one that could take us all just
a little bit closer to the Moon and Mars
it was incredible
appreciate all the hard work and thanks
for the great ride with space alley full
skew Sky News